i really hope there's life or traces of
previous life on mars this is a special
spot in my heart because i got to work
on sherlock which is the astrobiology
experiment that's on mars right now
searching for what they would say in a
very cautious way is signs of past
habitability they want to be careful not
to get people overly excited and say
we're searching for signs of life
they're searching to see if there would
have been organics on the surface of
mars or water in certain areas that
would have allowed for life to flourish
and i really love this prospect i do
think within our lifetimes we'll get a
better answer about finding life in our
solar system if it's there if not on
mars maybe europa
one of the icy worlds so you like the
you like
astrobiology i do because this is part
part of the so it's not just about human
biology it's also other extraterrestrial
alien biology search for life in the
universe okay yeah does that scare you
or excite you it excites me profoundly
there's other alien civilizations
potentially very different than our our
own i think there's got to be some
humility there and certainly from
science fiction we have plenty of
reasons to fear that outcome as well but
i do think as a scientist it would be
profoundly exciting if we were to find
life especially in the near neighborhood
of our solar system
right now we would expect it to be most
likely microbial life but we have a real
serious challenge in astrobiology which
is it may not even be carbon-based life
and all of our detectors we only know to
look for dna or rna
how would you even build a detector to
look for silicon based life
or different molecules than what we know
to be the fundamental molecules for life
and you mentioned offline sarah walker
she yes her the question that she's
obsessed with is even just defining life
what is life to look outside
the carbon base i mean to look outside
of basically anything we can even
imagine chemically uh to look outside of
any kind of notions that we think of as
biology
yeah it's it's really weird so you now
get into this land of like complexity of
a measuring
of like how many assembly steps it takes
to build that thing right and maybe
maybe uh dynamic movement or some
maintenance of some kind of membrane
structures like we don't even know like
which properties life should have
uh whether it can should be able to
reproduce and all those kinds of things
or past information genetic type of
information
we don't know and it's like it's that's
so humbling
i mean i tend to believe that there
could be
something like alien life here on earth
and we're just too
human biology obsessed to even recognize
it the shadow biosphere i remember you
and sarah was talking about i mean
that's like
speaking of beer i mean that's something
i wanted to make sure in all of science
to shake ourselves out of like remind
ourselves constantly how little we know
because it might be right in front of
our nose
like i wouldn't be surprised if like
trees are like orders of magnitude more
intelligent than humans they're just
operating at a much slower scale
and they're like talking [ __ ] about us
the whole time like about silly humans
that take everything seriously and we
start all kinds of nuclear wars and we
quarrel and we tweet about it and then
but the trees are always there just
watching us silly humans
like exactly
you